pour le savoir changeant de quartier
sinon cuisine sont venus chez vous pour
vous demander s il existe selon vous une
solution d'urbanisme pour paris il faut
annuler les effets d'une langue
médisance et chercher tous les moyens
par lesquels paris peut redevenir une
ville de beauté et d'harmonie briller
voire à la gentillesse de nous montrer
quelques exemples oui volontiers je vais
expliquer vous expliquer certains des
moyens par laquelle amp et atteindre le
but d'ailleurs je crois monsieur le
corps physique il ya très longtemps que
vous réfléchissez à ces problèmes
d'urbanisme trentaine d'années est ce
que vous êtes arrivé tout de suite au
plan définitif ou bien est ce qu'au
contraire vous avez eu des des étapes
successives
j'ai cherché très longtemps et j'ai créé
des plans successifs
j'ai eu l'occasion de les montrer
parfois dans des expositions de les
exposer dans des livres mais petit à
petit le silence s'étend sur ces choses
on n'a jamais répondu à ses plans non
non par des quolibets parfois ou ou même
l'opinion est saisi par rapport aux
diverses manifestations très nette qui
ont eu lieu en particulier celle du
pavillon des temps nouveaux
en 1937 à l'expression 37
est ce qu'on va les réunir en un livre
s'il signe précisément
le directeur des éditions de minuit m'a
demandé l'autre jour on m'a dit nous
allons publier les plans locaux bouzid
paris de 55 1922
c'est à dire voyez 33 ans de plans dans
un gros livre fait en offset qui
reproduira de l'été les airs est une
plante qui ont déjà été publiés qui sont
parus qui ont été soumises a loupé à
l'opinion ne peut être inattentif et
tout le tout rassembleur une seule heure
en un seul exemplaire en un seul volume
en gros volumes importants est ce que
vous auriez l'obligeant de faire
quelques dessins pour nous montrer
justement les étapes de cette théorie
oui vos lentilles je peux vous expliquer
en quelques instants
je prenne mon papier je vais vous
montrer comment paris est né sur un
fleuve
elle a croisé de sa route la première
ville fut dans des dimensions normales
puis sa crue tant ceinture considérable
successives jusqu'au roi et contenant
tout de même une masse de population
déjà très forte
provoquant au temps de louis xiv et
louis 15 un affolement déjà au moment où
les premiers carrosse apparurent est la
ville et on disait c'est une ville où
les hommes se marchent les uns sur les
autres
mais subitement au machiniste c'est à
dire un siècle après le désastre devient
totale car l'industrie se développe pas
autour de la ville ja en créant des
cités industrielles puis j'ai cité
ouvrière se tenir autour des cités
secteur industriel de banlieue et ainsi
de suite par ceinture successives la
ville fini par devenir tentaculaire
atteignant un diamètre de 50 80 km ou
davantage ou 100 km et et rendant ainsi
les transports absolument des transports
des transports les rendant absolument
impossible inefficace et jetant sur les
hommes un malaise à trop ce qui est
devenu maintenant catastrophique est
votre solution avoue d'abouti linverse
de ma solution c'est de reprendre le
problème à froid de regarder comment
sont les choses ou sont des événements
mettre de l'ordre dans quelque sorte et
d'obtenir par les examens doctrinal
suffisamment sain est vrai moins
d'obtenir la remise en ordre de paris et
voulez vous nous montrez le dessin vecta
cas d'un pari tout à fait possibles tels
que par exemple celui ci montre le pari
possible dans paris rentré chez lui hier
un pari mais ça ça oblige à les
destruction ce plan n'ont pas toute la
vie n'est faite que de destruction et de
reconstruction et particulièrement la
vie défiler voulez vous nous montrez ce
qui seraient détruits sur ce dessin
juste sur ce dessin de le centre qui est
déjà le qui est constamment qui s'est
constamment refait depuis la période
romaine période moyenâgeuse à perdre et
les princes des rois et des républiques
tous se sentent qu'ils seraient refaits
sur lui-même comme tout à fait phénomène
naturel peut redonner une vitalité
incroyable à paris grâce aux techniques
modernes qui offrent le chemin la
solution le pont pour passer une soirée
ccq et qu'on voit sur ce dessin au
milieu de ce dessin ce sont en fait les
délais les grandes maisons en fait 1 500
pas d'étude en profitant des techniques
modernes vous pouvez bâtir en hauteur et
obtenir par exemple tel qu'il est prévu
ici une cité d'affaires formelle de
quatre grands édifices
c'est suffisant de 200 mètres de hauteur
et se passer de 400 mètres les uns des
autres occupants de 5% de la surface
seulement les 130 95% sont pliés des
surfaces libres des parcs et 1 continue
de 400 m plus 400 m plus 400 m ça fait
trois fois 4,12 ça fait 200 m de parc
est à dire une immense distance où tous
les problèmes de circulation de trafics
illicites notamment décidé d'atterrir
voulait situés ou dans le pari régionale
et d'affaires bien se mettre là où le
mal est le plus fort et le plus
intenable en ce moment c'est où sont les
taudis qui sont actuellement derrière la
porte saint denis à la porte à porte
mais dites moi monsieur le corbusier
avec ce système est ce que vous n'aimez
pas justement complètement détruire le
paris historique
oh non non surtout pas sa salle
moi j'aime paris je suis venu de passer
ma vie entière depuis 50 ans et j'aime
paris et peu toute sa beauté qu'ici
organiquement organisé de long de la
seine et dans des lieux qui sont
pertinemment dessinée est limité tout le
passé paris se trouve en sur la rive
gauche est sur la rive droite avec une
évasion sur les champs elysées et au
delà de sad au nord de paris comme au
sud de paris
il n'y a que 1 développement il s'est
fait soit sous napoléon iii soit sous
les temps l'époque actuelle
quand une partie est un taudis ne faut
pas avoir de remords de l'enlever savait
pas aux hôtels n'ont qu'à y rester mcad
marais mais supposons fait cette
transformation selon selon votre plan
quelle serait la conséquence pratique de
cette transformation par rapport à
l'europe
et bien cette transformation
nécessite je voulais dit la prise en
considération des trois établissements
humains
les trois établissements humains
agricoles industriels et des changes
commerçants et l'idée n'est ce pas
nécessite occupent des places
spécifiques sur le territoire des places
fatidique hollandais talweg que je sais
les talwegs blessé avec ce sont les
valets d'écoulement des eaux
d'écoulement des zones d'écoulement des
dévents c'est ce sont ce sont des choses
absolument fatal qui occupent depuis la
préhistoire qui constitue la préhistoire
des cheminements les hommes enfin on
appelle ça les grandes routes du monde
la considération la prise en
considération des trois établissements
humains retrouves c'est avec et la 4e
route d'avion vin vient les rejoindre
tout naturellement car les avions
viennent là où il ya de l'activité
on peut donc lire en conclusion qu'avec
votre transformation paris deviendra en
quelque sorte l'oeil de l'europe